ma andiamo tutti allora il maggior di
ataka ciurma andiamo che ricorda tutti
ragazzi e video sono vari j oggi qui per
voi vi sono il cappellone l'attestato lo
zio perché sennò mi sono vestito per
l'occasione è anche se questa è una polo
però a prestate l'impegno soprattutto
per la spilla pila dove da apprezzare
qui sono il sito più di ragazzi perché
oggi che il 19 agosto esce per la prima
volta in italia la prima cosiddetto in
ufficiale delle miniature di voti ed
affamati come mi hanno inviato tutte le
miniature di one piece ho deciso di
farsi uno sketch un po bella ragazza
avevo proprio voglia di far serata dove
la disco nella ragazzo è frate mettiti
in fila ma io sono il protagonista
perché devo far la fila questi ragazzi
di oggi che non riconoscono l'importanza
dei protagonisti anche detti pippa veri
importante protagonisti ok ogni giorno
finalmente addio
finalmente sono due ore che sono in fila
c'era il quad non ed asma sono
protagonista non bisogna gettare tesi il
nome tonalità ciak a rufy vincere mezzo
lui prova con lupi cola cola lm
non c'è nessun ero piccola prova con
rubber
rava con nome del tuo canale eventi non
so come te lo devo dire io sono sulla
lista
[Musica]
grazie grazie tenuti tutti i giocatori
si grazie
ma grazie bomba per fare il cosplay del
cartello dolente ma presto un cartello
che questo e siccome il cappello di rufy
del sotto guai rosso
cio a volte intorno una cravatta che è
la cravatta di youtube cosplay di altri
tempi ragazzi vabbè lasciamo fuori
cappello seggi del pd ho cambiato
direttamente pure location mi devo
spiegare cosa sta succedendo perché
mentre sta montando il video sono in
vacanza quindi vedrete il miliardo di
location diversi questo blog curati di
euro già attiva la mia vita adesso vi
faccio vedere che cosa è successo
durante questa settimana perché pietro
quel bel ragazzo molto più bello di
questo signore qui è venuta a casa mia e
abbiamo cucinato il sushi cucinato il
sushi
tengo a precisare che tutto il cibo che
abbiamo toccato con le nostre belle
macchine non è andato sprecato maturati
accompagnato tutto guarigione sì però
noi mangiamo poi questa roba che
cuciniamo e sapete che il veleno in
confronto è una cosa buona
allora abbiamo preso il salmone europa
poi fu cosi del mare sono i più
improbabili granchio ragazzi la cosa su
per te la chicca di oggi è larga è
esattamente quella che usano gli
struggimenti
si chiamano recente per sushi bar ogni
bara sushi ma che cucinano sushi che è
veramente piegato renzo si è offerto di
andare alzati il salmone in fettine o
non è bello vederti in sarete tagliando
il salmone stare a faccio io sono calati
ma il coltello dalla punta arrotondata
come possiamo
sentitelo rovesciamo bene qualsiasi sito
faccio io
cominciamo con liriche sono i primi di
rendita il riso e mi fai delle falle la
pelle un abbonamento sito non si
prospetta bilite molto più compatto
professionisti ai quali venne un piatto
o raga il fascinoso far bene questo dove
caste dal piatto dove andremo a
posizionare tutte quante le nostre
creazioni porca di tecnico da simi pensa
cv il fascinoso fare da dio ce l'hai
bravo bravo bravissimo
bravo 100 100 mila a posto l'edilizia
dell'iri le fatto benissimo a quegli
strani giri lo sappiamo fare adesso
passiamo a qualcosa di un po più
l'abbraccio toccare qualcosa ma chi
gioioso marchi si fanno con l'utilizzo
anche della pratica al taglio da piccolo
non essendo stato per tagli alla carta
mettilo qua mettilo su questo punto qui
così è bravo bravo ed attore dato è
bravissimo bavagli si automatico dai
4mila proposito questo moroso marchi non
ci poi così come per le sigarette per
chiuderla devo fare di po vecchi magari
paziente senza di numeri ma che spiego
non agitare
dovremmo tutti fare niente allora lo
zoom archi xvi prende larga lasci mette
in un piatto pulito si prende il riso e
lo si mette poi gigante italia ti fidi
di me poi si prende una bella questo di
salmone ho capito potrò tagliarmi errore
no ma no dai quattro pirla ma se un
cretino facendo come fare un appello
guarda aspetta poi si fa così e vero non
ci pensa voli
ed ecco è la versione di quella che ho
fatto io sono più grande perfetto la un
fenomeno io al canavacciolo io qua
sempre più i talenti poi lungo regia
quindi cosa dirà attimo e restiamo nel
banco del pesce bello ighalo pagandola
ci vogliono ricapitolando tu per ora
abbiamo fatto abbiamo dell'ottimo
hosomaki ben chiuso vedo tra ci siamo
impegnati il sashimi e perpetuo e dei
bicchieri che sembrano legni chirico dei
problemi però possiamo fare il cono il
gunkan quello so come si fa faccio io
faccio io ho visto alla reagan cani
teoria sarebbe questo credo sia questo
league anche ragazzi allora facciamo
innanzitutto faccio io volevo fare io
questo siano vivi sebbene signore ci
illustra cosa ma posto all gunkan più o
meno sembra un cono rapporto chef che
l'impianto im piazzamento la loro di
allenamento e importante quindi bisogna
è il piatto presenti bene
e farne un po di peso atto non buona
presenza io rimarrei subito da tutto
questo
trattenga al suo orgasmo si apre un
ristorante a milano non lo diamo qui e
mi tranquillamente dell'ordine robe del
genere
lo capiamo avremo tante richieste però
cerchio logica forse anche lei è andata
abbiamo anche preso la tratta di soia è
da sempre quella che trovi in tutti i
lamenti mio assoluto degli one of the
reverse inoltre la chicca varie lotte
l'immancabile banche e quindi così prego
almeno solo uno è doveroso dare questa
sera non mi rovinate la cacchione allora
capace li stai rovinando
ma perché non sei maledizione il mio di
vini by bravo l'alt ad una vittoria
nella ii per bellezza marito di video
tiene erigono male vai cioè soia o
rapetti pietro fa schifo è buono a
quanto vedo fattivo secondo me non è non
dovrebbe essere malissimo larga quanto
scritto veramente la è la cosa fatta
meglio ma perché in realtà presenta un
po di macro e penso veramente buona aver
urto prestissimo trovava maniero non è
possibile che un metro ragazzi io
ringrazio pietro per questa è il mio
video quello quindi l'aria questa parte
dei flussi vila sospetto finale del long
ci sono un sacco di trani in questo
video dove lo stesso vi sia piaciuto
sono riuscito a farlo anche grazie al
mio socio qua anche mezzo da marro siamo
pirata
straniero va detto che volevo dirvi che
il minatore che abbiamo utilizzato e con
ogni due settimane in edicola a partire
da questa settimana qui se volete la mia
maglietta e la mia che la mia maglietta
12 materna vagliati non mi starà mai
perché sono magro però aver scoperto
laudrup e la maglietta questa qui ve la
regala note di abbonate al volano per
avere tutte le uscite di urby se siamo
allora neanche più un capitolo e l'altro
la maglietta vi danno anche le cartoline
che sono queste quale dono 90 possibile
ma è già state prima e oltre quelle vi
danno anche la tata di morbilità e ti
l'amante vero il portachiavi vivo a
cristo comunque quest'arena quale hai
fatto in elemento consiglieri volti al
copione non stavo guardando la rena
parla sì mi vuoi bene di ottimo 20 città
si fa chiamare tanti ragazzi conclude
volevo dirvi che questa settimana esce
ruby con il forte del fascicolo e poi li
quest'ultima ne sono anche gli altri
io volevo concludere allungandomi sul
web cam
però purtroppo non ho acquistato i
poteri di allungamento proprio video vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi spero che possiate
capire il caldo che ti prova mi ha fatto
malissimo mi ha fatto maledetta spilla
cioè l'età recitare a tifosi e invece
gia sul momento e mi piace anche marito
ha riconosciuto
tiziana tornava tv sede ci vediamo in
possibilità dare a tutti con sarebbe
prendere il telecomando mulligan si
vabbè fantasticherie variati
[Musica]
ancora